- [Instructor] In any
textbook overview of Hinduism
you will quickly encounter
the caste system,
and the caste system is the
notion that people are born
into the roles that they
have to play in society.
Now the reason why I put this in quotes
is because they're associated this notion
from the various Hindu
scripture of Varnas,
but the best translation from Sanskrit
into English of Varnas is classes.
And it's interesting
to think about whether
they were first intended
to be just social classes,
or also hereditary classes
as the caste system implies.
What we do know is that as
we approach modern Hinduism
over the last several hundred years,
it did approach something that was more
what you are born into.
But we'll look a little
bit at the scripture
and I'll leave it up to you to decide
whether it was more of a social class
or if it was a class
that you were born into.
Now the four Varnas that
are described in the Vedas
and other Hindu scripture,
at the top you have the Brahmins
who are the priests and the teachers,
not to be confused with the god Brahma
or the ultimate reality, Brahman.
Next you have the Kshatriyas
who are the warriors and rulers.
And it's interesting that
at least in Hindu society
the Brahmins were considered higher
than the warriors, the rulers, the kings.
After that you have the Vaishyas
who are the farmers, the merchants.
And then next the Shudras, the laborers,
those who worked in service
to the other three classes.
Now you also had and have
people who are outside
of these four different classes.
Today they refer to themselves as Dalits,
which means the oppressed,
but sometimes they've been
referred to as untouchable,
and that's because in
traditional Hindu society
many of these people weren't
even able to enter temples,
they were discriminated against,
they didn't have access to resources,
they weren't even allowed to shake hands
or make physical contact
with other members
of Hindu society.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about how this may
or may not be changing.
Now to see the basis of the
Varna system in scripture
I will start with this
quote from the Rigveda.
Now this is from the Purusha Sukta,
and Purusha in the Vedas you
can view as this cosmic being,
but they anthropomorphize this being,
making it seem or making an
analogy with a human body.
"When they divided the Cosmic Being,
"how many portions did they make?
"What do they call his mouth, his arms?
"What do they call his thighs and feet?
"The Brahmin was his mouth,
"of both arms was the Rajanya made."
The Rajanya you could
view as the Kshatriyas,
the warriors and the kings.
"His thighs became the Vaishya,
"from his feet the Sudra was produced."
So in the Vedas, and there's some dispute
about whether this was
originally in the Vedas
or about whether it was added later,
to have a creation story,
but it is making reference
to these four Varnas.
But here it is not 100%
clear whether it's just
talking about the various
classes of society.
You're bound to have some
priests and teachers,
some warriors and rulers,
some farmers, merchants,
some laborers.
Or are they saying
something more fundamental?
Now we can go to the
time of the Mahabharata,
when the Mahabharata was written
and the subset of the Mahabharata
which is the Bhagavad Gita,
and they also make reference
to this Varna system.
So the Bhagavad Gita is
the part of the Mahabharata
where you have Krishna talking to Arjuna
and reassuring him about his role in life,
and this is what Krishna tells Arjuna.
"A Brahman's virtues, born
of his nature, are serenity,
"self-control, austerity,
purity, tolerance,
"honesty, learning, and to know the truth
"of things which be.
"A Kshatriya's pride, born of his nature,
"lives in valor,
exuberance, determination,
"resourcefulness, bravery in battle,
"and generosity and noble
demeanor as a lord of men.
"A Vaisya's task, born with his nature,
"is to till the ground,
tend cattle, venture trade.
"A Sudra's state, suiting
his nature, is service."
Arguably in service to
the other three classes.
Now once again, it doesn't
make strict reference
to you are born a Brahmin,
if your father was a Brahmin
then you have to be a Brahmin,
or if your father was a Kshatriya,
you will be a Kshatriya.
It is making reference to this idea
of being "born of his nature."
So you could interpret that as,
this is this idea that you
have some innate gifts,
you have some innate tendencies,
and those innate tendencies
are going to dictate
whether you're going to
be a Brahmin, a Kshatriya,
a Vaisya, or a Shudra.
I encourage you as always to look up
the primary documents yourself,
and especially when you're
looking at something
that is a translation,
this is a translation
from Sanskrit to English,
how it is translated matters.
So try to look up multiple translations
and come to your own conclusion.
Now regardless of whether
the ancient Hindu scripture,
the Bhagavad Gita is over 2,000 years old,
if we're talking about the Vedas
and especially if the Purusha Sukta
was part of the original Vedas,
we're talking about something
that's over 3,000 years old,
regardless of the original
intent of the Varna system,
whether it was supposed to
be just talking about classes
as opposed to a hereditary caste,
the reality is is over the
last several hundred years
in India it did become a caste.
People whose parents were
Brahmins became Brahmins.
Kshatriyas became Kshatriyas.
And they married amongst themselves,
and it did dictate their social status.
And so to put all of this in perspective
I'm going to give you a quote from
really one of India's founding fathers.
So this is a picture of B.R. Ambedkar
and he was born a Dalit,
and faced significant discrimination
when he was growing up.
He wasn't allowed to sit on chairs
or eat next to his fellow students.
As you can imagine his family
wouldn't have had access
to nowhere near the
resources that other people
in the village or in the city
would have had access to.
They would have been
actively discriminated with,
they wouldn't have even been
able to make physical contact
with members of the formal Varna system.
But despite all of that discrimination
he was able to get a significant education
and eventually become
India's first Law Minister,
and not only that, but
the principal architect
of the Indian Constitution.
And this is what he wrote
about the caste system.
"Caste is not a physical
object like a wall of bricks
"or a line of barbed wire
which prevents the Hindus
"from co-mingling and which has
therefore to be pulled down.
"Caste is a notion, it
is a state of the mind."
And if you look at modern India
or if you talk to modern Hindus,
many of them will say hey, we
don't take caste seriously.
We view this as a part of our past,
and a part of our past
that we're not necessarily that proud of.
But there are still Hindus who do take
the caste system seriously,
especially if you go into
rural areas and villages.
Many of the things that
B.R. Ambedkar faced,
this level of discrimination,
of Dalits not being able to go a temple,
not having access to water resources,
this is still happening in India.
And in things like
inter-marriage the caste system
is still taken reasonably
seriously by a large portion
of the Hindu population.
Now here's another quote
from B.R. Ambedkar.
"Some men say that they
should be satisfied
"with the abolition of
untouchability only,
"leaving the caste system alone.
"The aim of abolition
of untouchability alone
"without trying to
abolish the inequalities
"inherent in the caste
system is a rather low aim."